doñana se caractérise par être une zone humide
et ce que nous pouvons voir est un secarral
un sécarral est un désert
[Musique]
la surexploitation des eaux
le métro tue le
les zones humides de doñana et je suis très sceptique
s'il n'y a pas de changements radicaux et que
des changements radicaux passeraient par l'arrêt du
surexploitation de la nappe proche
puits et limiter les extractions
et les couper en deux
dans la municipalité d'el monte nous avons 4 mille
200 hectares de terres irriguées
s'ils réduisent la dotation de moitié
nous devons réduire la culture au
la moitié c'est une vraie ruine
[Musique]
le problème a une solution très simple
Quel est le transfert d'eau du
blague jusqu'à ce que le comté de huelva il n'y ait pas
problème d'eau crée un problème
l'artificiel est un mensonge ici l'eau ne manque pas
ni doñana n'est en danger si elle est prononcée dans
cette oeuvre
[Musique]
nous pensons que cela peut causer des dommages
réputation importante chez le client
final et le client final peut penser
que tout ce qui pousse à Huelva est
illégal et rejeter nos produits
[Musique]